tanya is is with us in our today I'm
sorry is with us in Houston is it today
yeah there we go cool how can I help
alright of all baby such a honor to be
able to speak to you well you too thank
you um my dilemma is my fiance your
phone your phone your phone sounds like
it's on a speakerphone is it yeah it was
good thank you thank you my fiance
I found out that he owes IRS over two
hundred thousand dollars so I don't know
if we can still get married or how do I
approach it why what is it why does he
owe the IRS $200,000 well he's pretty
much a contractor well he's like a
self-employed truck driver and so I just
never paid his taxes probably not okay
and what's his plan going forward on
paying taxes well he says he wants to
pay it off I don't know that he's
actually you know in the process of
doing anything he's not been that
transparent with his intentions as far
as that goes but he wants to get married
this year yeah or in 2017 then he's
gonna have to get his act together at
nee yeah cuz you don't marry a guy that
doesn't have his act together you know
that and right now right now he I don't
mind the debt I mind how irresponsible
he's being about it and that's your big
brother talking to you right now okay
thank so yeah you know you don't want be
ten years from now still be dealing with
this because you marry into it and he's
not dealing with it so a condition of
you guys continuing forward in this
relationship is is that he deal he
begins a process of cleaning this up
now there's two or three things he needs
to do are you ready here's relates to do
go to Dave Ramsey calm and click on ELP
for taxes endorsed local provider for
the person we recommend for helping
people with taxes one of our LPS will be
able to help him
a couple of things number one is we have
to go no further in debt which means he
needs to start setting aside a portion
of his check every week every month to
pay his taxes going forward so we don't
know any further in the hole that's a
big big step number two I'm guessing he
hadn't even filed his tax return or
maybe he has and that's how he knows how
much taxes he owes as he well I believe
that yeah I believe he did this year
because he had a daughter going off to
college and I kind of held up her
regrets or anything so that's how it
came out probably alright so we need to
get he needs to get those tax returns
and then there's two possibilities you
know what he earns I would say or a
minimum at minimum at least seventy
before his expenses his truck expenses
and things like that then my guess is
what's going to happen on the back taxes
that he owes he's going to put that on a
payment plan and it's going to take a
while but he needs to get it on a
payment plan so they don't come and
suddenly disrupt your all's life by
taking crap out of your house okay
that's what they'll do they don't fool
around the IRS has an amazing amount of
power you do not mess with them okay so
we need to get the back taxes on a
payment plan and the taxes going forward
are going to be paid starting today
ready set go and he needs to sit down
with somebody to help him do that and
put that together now there's one other
possibility I don't think it'll work but
you can investigate it it's called an oh
I see an offer and compromise okay oh I
see offering compromise and that is
where you settle the debt with the IRS
in other words they'll you know maybe
maybe they'll take $20,000 as a
settlement on 200,000 but but the only
way they do that is if they believe
they're never going to get their money
and that usually involves you have
almost no income and I'm afraid his
incomes - how to qualify okay but I'm
going to ask about it if I'm in your old
shoes and
learn what the guidelines currently are
for an OIC it's very very difficult
almost impossible to get an OIC through
the IRS right now but but it's worth
asking about because there's $200,000 on
the line hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]